DEPORTED.
JESSE: THANKS, AND GO FIX YOUR
HAIR, IT'S A MESS.
>> THANK YOU, JESSE.
JESSE: JOINING US, UNTIL --
FORMER CONGRESSWOMAN TULSI
GABBARD.
EVERYBODY WITH A BRAIN KNOWS
THERE WAS NO WHIPPING OF
MIGRANTS GOING ON.
WHY IS HE SAYING IT DID AND
THREATENING TO PUNISH THE
AGENTS?
>> THE ISSUE HERE -- AND I
CONSIDER JOE BIDEN A FRIEND.
BUT HE'S ABSOLUTELY WRONG AND HE
NEEDS TO APOLOGIZE TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE FOR SAY WEIGHING
SAID.
HE'S BEEN VERY OUTSPOKEN BEING
ANSWER AUTOCRATS AND DICTATORS.
BUT WHAT HE DID WAS ACT AS
JUDGE, JURY AND EXECUTIONER FOR
THESE CUSTOMS AND BORDER PATROL
AGENTS ON HORSEBACK.
HOW CAN THEY EXPECT TO HAVE A
FAIR OUTCOME TO AN INVESTIGATION
WHEN THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES HAS DECLARED THEIR GUILT
AND THEY WILL BE PUNISHED.
THE BIGGER ISSUE THIS POINTS TO
WHICH IS ONE WE ALL NEED TO BE
CONCERNED ABOUT IS IF WE ARE NO
LONGER A COUNTRY OF LAWS, IF WE
ARE NO LONGER A COUNTRY WHERE WE
KNOW WE'LL BE PRESUMED INNOCENT
UNLESS PROVEN GUILTY, THEN WE
DON'T HAVE A DEMOCRACY.
THAT'S AN INCREASING FEELING A
LOT OF US HAVE IS WE ARE LOSING
OUR DEMOCRACY.
JESSE: THIS IS THE KIND OF HOAX
THEY USE ON POLICE OFFICERS
WHERE THEY TAKE SOMETHING OUT OF
CONTEXT OR HEAR SOMETHING FROM
ONE PERSPECTIVE, AND THEY
CONVICT THE PERSON.
IT CREATES A LOT OF ANIMOSITY IN
THIS COUNTRY.
YOU SAW THIS HOAX WITH RUSSIA.
WHEN THE CLINTON CAMPAIGN PLANTS
FAKE NEWS ABOUT TRUMP AND
RUSSIA.
THAT LASTED YEARS.
THAT WAS A HOAX.
THIS TYPE OF DISINFORMATION IS
SO DANGEROUS TO THE COUNTRY.
I FEEL LIKE THEY GOT AWAY WITH
IT SO MANY TIMES THAT MANY PART
OF THEIR PLAYBOOK AND THEY WILL
KEEP DOING IT OVER AND OVER
AGAIN UNTIL WHEN?
WHEN ARE THEY EVER GOING TO
STOP?
>> THE SADDEST PART ABOUT THIS,
THEY ARE GETTING AWAY WITH IT,
AND IT'S THE POWERFUL ELITES
WORKING WITH THE MEDIA AND THE
POWERFUL INTERESTS.
TO PRESERVE THEIR POWER OR
POSITION OR MONEY.
WHATEVER THEIR SELFISH DRIVE IS,
THEY ARE UNWILLING TO SACRIFICE
THEIR INTERESTS FOR THE INTEREST
OF THE COUNTRY.
THEY HAVE NO BUSINESS BEING IN
POSITIONS OF LEADERSHIP AT ANY
LEVEL OF OUR SOCIETY.
WHO SUFFERS AS A RESULT OF THIS?
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
OUR DEMOCRACY.
THIS IS WHY LEADERSHIP THAT PUTS
SERVICE ABOVE SELF AND THE
INTERESTS OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
AND OUR COUNTRY FIRST IS SO
CRITICAL AND ESSENTIAL,
ESPECIALLY NOW.
JESSE: THAT WAS VERY WELL SAID.
YOU SAID JOE IS YOUR FRIEND, THE
PRESIDENT.
MAYBE YOU CAN GET HIM ON THE
PHONE AND TELL HIM YOUR OPINION.
MAYBE HE DOESN'T WATCH "WATTERS'